- Oh dang, my fingers crushed another phone.
- [Ja Morant:] LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
ANSWERING A VIDEO CHAT
FROM ZION WILLIAMSON...
JA MORANT
- Haha, I’m so bored too.
Guess we may not find out
who’s Rookie of the Year after all.
- The season ain’t over.
I’m playing full games in here.
- Yeah,
I was thinking about streaming 2K
while mumbling later.
- No,
I’m playing for real.
Another three for the presumptive
Rookie of the Year.
- Bro, are you OK?
Has anyone on your team
checked in on you?
- I’ve got the whole team here!
See?
It's Jonas Valanciunas.
[Imitating Jonas] Good day, teammate.
Oh hey, Jaren Jackson Jr.
What up, Dillon Brooks?
- Uh- oh. He’s making up fake people now.
Ja, basketball will come back, man,
but we gotta take it easy.
- Inside the NBA, don’t you think we should
still give out NBA awards?
[Imitating Kenny] He has a point.
[Imitating Shaq] What’s Ja Morant’s last name?
[Imitating Chuck] Shaq, you dumb idiot.
[Imitating Ernie] Boys, we mustn't fight!
- Oh man, my one year at Duke didn't
prepare me for stuff like this.
- Ja starts the second half.
He goes around the screen.
TO THE PAINT!
- Ja, are you OK?
- NO ONE ELSE CAN WIN ROOKIE OF THE YEAR
IF I’M THE ONLY ONE PLAYING.
- I gotta bring in help.
Think, Zion.
Who’s always by their phone?
Oh, duh.
- Aw, you ruined my tok!
- If you.
- Liked
- This video
- Subscribe below
- For more.
- Or we’re not
- Jason
- And Jason McCourtey.
- No, you’re Devin.
- I’m pretty sure you’re Devin.
- Which of us is Devin?
- Uh, you!
- ME?
- I’ll be Devin.
- Thanks Jason.